hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today is august 27th which means the
large core combat update patch title
update whatever you want to call it
is now live it is actually in game right
now as i'm making this video so all you
need to do is just download the update
it's about a gig for any platform that
you played on so it shouldn't be too
large
and also i will be leaving this down in
the comments down below as i
highly recommend you check this out
after this video is done
as there is a lot of information as
we'll soon get to but do keep in mind
that if you do see this there's a bunch
of different things like
patch note 2.20.0 and then 2.20.2
2.20.0 was what we covered a couple
weeks ago this is just showing the
transition
from the old patch to the new patch as
today we're talking about 2.20.2
i hope that didn't confuse you either
way like to be if you're doing just
subscribe if you're new
let's get started with today's video so
the first one has to do with warmonger
and in specific the corruption feat
while this also
affects nusha as well since it infection
technically counts as a corruption feat
but for nusha and warmonger's feats
corruption is no longer triggered by
having soldiers from your team
in the aoe so as long as you are using
infection or the fourth tier feet or
maybe honestly even the first tier fee
from warmonger
obviously when you hit the opponent they
will take damage if there's
any soldiers nearby this is now not the
case
for corruption blade for warmonger
specifically this is going to decrease
activation time before going to cool
down without hitting a target
to 15 seconds from 20 and then increase
cooldown
to 75 seconds so nerf all around and
then the corruption blast the cooldown
is now 180 as opposed to 150 so now it's
three whole minutes we talked about this
before in the little teaser but
just to let you know attacks performed
with the light attack input are now
going to be costing nine stamina and
then the combo lights following after
will be costing six stamina
this is for most of those characters
especially xiao lin in this case where i
believe his triple light attack
the death point strike is a shitload of
stamina for
little damage so that's one of those
that's definitely going to be greatly
affected in a good way
now this is the biggest portion of the
patch notes so we're going to dissect
this
really quickly it says the developer
comment we've adjusted the damage for
multiple attacks on average heavy
attacks deal less damage and
light attacks remain mostly the same but
there are some exceptions
the new damage values are closer but not
identical to the testing grounds week
two
we looked at community feedback and our
own internal feedback and examined every
attack in regard to its utility and
properties and rebalance their damage
accordingly
this was done to ensure that fights last
a bit longer punishes are less damaging
and players have more time to anticipate
what their opponent is doing
we've also raised the zone attack damage
for the heroes that rely on them
as the soul guard break punish just
wanted to throw that in there in the
beginning as that's the
sole intent purpose of why these damage
values were adjusted and
every single character has been affected
by this even the new character warmonger
so
this is definitely important for
everyone who watches this video
now this is gonna just be shown in
alphabetical order and as you'll see
i'm not gonna be talking through this
part as there is loads of different data
values and i don't want to confuse
anybody or bore anyone or anything like
that so
i'll just be taking screenshots from the
actual post itself
and i'll be flashing them up on screen
if any character comes up that is
important to you a character you play a
character you might play or a character
that you just face all the time
feel free to pause and look at the stats
accordingly and of course
you can always just check the full patch
at the in the link down in the
description
as this is definitely the largest part
of the patch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i mean i wasn't lying that was an
extremely large amount of data
and like i said that's the reason why i
didn't want to say any of it as i didn't
want to
you know completely confuse anyone that
was just going through and listening to
this
and not looking at their screen or
anything like that but we're still not
done we still have these stamina damage
adjustments and this one i will talk
through as it's not as long as the
previous
but the following attack stamina drain
has been adjusted to drain 30 stamina
instead of their previous values so
valkyries left and right light finishers
they used to do 80
but now they're going to be doing 30.
shield bash is
was 40 and now 30. for gladiator his
perry punish was 60 and bamboozle was
50. once again israel to 30.
tiandi's kick was 35 shaolin sprint
attack was
40. a fully charged finisher punch from
centaurion was 40
and then the gb punish on the third hit
used to be 35.
lawbringer's chain top heavy is 35. our
amusha's kick was 40
nobushi's kick was 40. shugoky's
headbutt was 50
and warlord's parry punish was 60. now
like i said those are all going to be 30
so
there is no reason to be saying 230 from
60 or 230 from 50 as as all of them are
just 30 stamina damage so
just keep that in mind any of the
characters you play those are not going
to be costing less stamina to do those
moves which is a good thing
and then one thing for the recovery
adjustment is that for sugoki's light
attack you now have
833 milliseconds of recovery on a hit
and 733 milliseconds of recovery on a
block
this is to ensure he's not frame
advantaged after his light attacks
and that was pretty much it the rest of
it just entails the patch note 2.20.1
which has to do with the patch we talked
about i believe
a couple weeks ago and then 2.20.0 which
was another patch we talked about
even longer than that one so these are
just detailing the past couple patches
we've seen which of course relate to the
core combat update in some way
but the most important one as of right
now is 2.20.2
especially because it has the most
amount of information
but if you do want to see that the blog
post that i linked down in the
description
is going to be covering twenty point
zero all the way to two point twenty
point two
so of course i think the best way to
read this new article is pretty much
find characters that you play the most
go all the way down to the bottom start
from there as that's the earliest that
was
the patches being made and then go from
there look at any characters that you
enjoy
make a mental note of what those are and
then just go on your way
it's too much information to look
through every single character at once
so
just care about the characters that you
play and yeah that's gonna be the end of
today's video guys hope you guys did
enjoy like to be if you did
subscribe if you're new i cover the
informational side of for honor and with
that
take care guys have a good yesterday let
me know what you guys think about the
big patch in the comments down below
peace out
[Music]
you